let's jump to the store because we do
have big news kiss co-founder Paul
Stanley 71 slams parents who confuse
their children about gender identity
branding child sex changes a sad and
dangerous fad this is the front man this
is the guy the star on his face for kiss
yeah this is the guy star child star
child that doesn't even look bad he's 71
isn't that crazy yeah he doesn't look
bad and uh he's aged better than me look
at that does he have the here we go he
says uh I'll read some of what he says
there's a big difference between
teaching acceptance and normalizing and
even encouraging participation in a
lifestyle that confuses young children
into questioning their sexual
identification as though some sort of
game and then parents in some cases
allow it he says there are individuals
who as adults may decide reassignment as
their needed choice but turning this
into a game or parents normalizing it as
some sort of natural alternative or
believing that because a little boy
likes to play just in his sister's
clothes or a girl and her brothers we
should lead them steps further down a
path that's far from the innocence of
what they're doing I I think uh uh I
think he's completely right you know
kids will will play with whatever toys
because they're just kids they're
exploring the world and what's happening
now is this is the meme it's a kid
playing with a doll and then the parent
says I'll prep the surgery right it's
like oh you play with the doll well
there it is the funny thing is and I've
pointed this out so as many other many
others how is it that they argue
simultaneously that gender is a social
construct meaning playing with dolls is
not unique to males or females but then
if a male or if a male plays with dolls
or a female with a football that proves
they're actually identifying as the
opposite sex the weird thing too is uh
the genderization of toys and clothes
came I came like after my childhood
after my brother's childhood and you
started to go into the Lego section and
you would see girls LEGOs and boys Legos
that didn't used to be the thing when I
would hang out and my friend Nikki's
basement and play with her brother's
Legos we just we just all played Legos
it wasn't a big deal and the same thing
with the Barbie dolls like we would just
all play it wasn't a big deal no I
joined I joined a girl Lego competition
and I just crushed I crushed I joined a
girls Barbie competition even and I
still beat them it was incredible
I would just like to say like I would
kick your ass in Barbies in all
seriousness there was a clip I saw from
your show and I can't remember the
guests and if you can please shout him
out but he was saying there were studies
on how boys and girls will play
differently they'll play with the same
toy yeah but when the boy picks up the
toy he starts embodying the character
he's playing with whereas when the girl
picks up the toy she has the character
act the way she does so even when we're
playing with her as kids playing with
different toys we we are the same yeah
the way he described it I feel bad that
I can't remember who it was but the way
he described it is when a boy picks up a
Batman toy now he's Batman he's like I'm
Batman he's just playing like Batman
when the girl picks Batman up Batman's
like do you want to have a tea party
then Batman wants a teapot exactly like
Batman actually play Barbies with my
friends at my mom's apartment and uh
like the neighbors and stuff we had this
guy Barbie Dreamhouse dream house and my
friend Julia's brother came to play with
us and he was older he was like 12 I
want to say and we were like 10 or
something but he took one of my Barbies
that was disabled and strapped together
with them rubber bands and he was like
this this is the Madam of the Barbie
dream house and we were like what's that
oh my God
television and its consequences have
been a disaster for the human race
we had the Barbie brothel we had like
all things set up it was ridiculous and
I told my mom about it I was like oh
Mark said this and that and my mom was
like I can't go over there anymore
it was Ethan van scriver it was said
that Ethan van scriver with the uh the
um comic yeah artists awesome yeah
someone mentioned in the chat so I I
wouldn't know because I've never been
female but when I used to play with Lego
was you're right when I would play with
toys
me and my friends would take the action
figures or whatever and we would voice
them we would be like I am going to take
over the world like we were the
character was was us we were like acting
as them that's what we used to do with
the Barbies we'd like well that's the
opposite of what you're saying yeah
I was told we would do like stories we
would like invent whole worlds with the
Barbies and mostly they ended up having
sex the issue is when you would play
with Barbie was the Barbie channeling
you and you were like I'm Barbie and
Barbie would do things so Barbie was
another character
like the character of the you know see I
distinctly remember when I was like we
do the voices would be like I'm going
over here now yeah when I was a kid like
if I was playing with like GI Joes or
whatever and my cut like cousins were
playing with Barbie or whatever and they
wanted to like have the Barbies and the
GI Joes interact I would get upset
because they would want the GI Joes to
do like Barbie things and I'm like no GI
Joes don't do that yeah yeah they're
going to fight then and they would be
like no that's why my cousin would be
like he had the Hulk Hogan and the Rowdy
Roddy Piper guys and so whenever I
played Barbies with him it was like
wrestling Barbie yes would they have
like the GI Joes at the mall with the
Barbies and then one gym
other and he goes hey that uniform what
what uh platoon were you with it was
stolen valor this guy
I don't I don't think Stolen Valor was
really a thing back then to be honest
I'm sure it was they just got away with
it because no one was filming it
yeah D Snyder came out on Twitter and
actually agreed with Paul Stanley and so
I'm feeling I'm feeling pretty confident
and I'm feeling pretty white pilled as
of lately because I think I think what's
happening is that we are reaching well
critical mass I think Bud Light is very
very important in more ways than people
realize the fact that Bud Light sales
are down 21.4 percent suggests to
regular people who are the people who
are like I don't know what's right or
wrong I just want to be on the right
side of History are now going maybe it's
not the woke people yep if Rock Stars
celebrities and the average person is
not buying this beer anymore so now
imagine this Bud Light is uncool nobody
wants to buy it now you're going to see
that rejection of this because a regular
person who normally just follows the
trends it's gonna be like I I don't I
don't drink Bud Light whatever you say
guys and then a beer company is going to
hire an actual woman to advertise their
beer
it used to be that the joke was uh the
joke Family Guy no don't do that they're
really kind of revolutionary say that uh
uh drink our beer and beautiful women
will want to have sex with you and the
commercial was women that was that was
the commercial and now the commercial is
if you drink Bud Light you are sexually
attracted to people of the same sex as
you and I don't think your average guy
who's going to a barbecue wants to
convey that message to his neighbors so
they're just like that's not my I don't
drink that stuff don't look at me Bud
Light it's reverse conversion therapy
cut your wiener off so I mean they used
to sell sex for everything I think
they're um when it comes to a lot of
alcoholic drinks like Bacardi Silver or
oh or whatever I don't know if they
still have those but like Fruity light
drinks and wine coolers or whatever are
seen as effeminate and guys want to
drink like Guinness like a strong dark
beer or something so now you have Bud
Light being like the frilliest of Fufu
Brands exactly
right stating like yeah like white Claw
is more masculine if they weren't right
yep if they were selling like strawberry
daiquiris I could understand
yeah
but now you have a beer that is widely
seen as effeminate and surprise surprise
to all of the woke gen's ears or
whatever guys don't want to be seen as
weak and to be fair drinks beer like
dudes drink beer women buy those fruity
things those like Bud Lights are the
beer that you get for like the hour or
where the beer that like you'd get for
the afternoon because you didn't want to
have like too heavy beer and it's kind
of thirst quenching and stuff and then
you drink the heavier stuff later it's
nobody's doing that anymore no one's
drinking that it's the beer that you buy
because you're not only manly enough to
drink beer you're manly enough to not
care if anyone you're with wants good
beer so you bring that over that's the
demographic they're like Dylan Mulvaney
that's who will slap out shut up and
drink it is pretty masculine right my
main point with bringing the subject uh
back up is
regular people the left is trying to win
the culture War by saying you are on the
wrong side of history and because civil
rights is the right side of History they
are trying to pretend that they
represent civil rights when in fact they
represent segregation and fashion and
fascism
ideologies but they're wearing a mask of
civil rights now that regular people
though are saying no to Bud Light
many people who are following the walk
are going to question whether or not
that's the safe place to be because they
were just going along with the crowd hey
the crowd's not there man the crowd's
clearly boycotting Bud Light what ended
up happening to gillette's numbers after
that out I think it's there a men's
brand they were a men's brand and I
remember people saying go woke get broke
or get woke go broke I'll tell you what
happens when Hershey's had a male
sponsor their women's candy bar that
Canadian we got that crazy delicious is
she her candy bar by Jeremy's chocolates
isn't it and I will stress they don't
pay me to do this no they do not dude
people and it's funny because whenever
anyone responds I know but I feel weird
chewing into the microwave I'll just
push the microphone unbelievable I'll
just chew over here I was there you go
uh whenever these boycotts happen people
go oh absolutely why do you care so much
I don't know because it's being forced
onto me at all times by everyone because
we're literally a year away from s the D
bigot no dude that was like two years
ago well I mean yeah that that was the
joke two years ago I really do it's
getting to the point where there are
people that do me and not that there's a
lot of people that support the argument
there are people that do make the art
the argument that if you won't date a
trans woman if you're a straight man and
you won't date a trans women you're a
bigot and I don't give a I'm a
bigot I don't care if you know who
really gets pushed that has this pushed
on them as are lesbians yeah yeah
lesbians are like wait I'm not doing the
right thing what am I supposed to do let
me do the right thing I'll I'll do the
thing and so yeah lesbians are easy to
push around it turns out you know the
crazy thing like a lot of women I was I
was right before that in Iran if you're
a gay man they force you get a sex
change and if you're a gay woman the
same thing yeah but now what we're
seeing is these young women who are like
autistic and gay are being told they're
trans and should get you know sex
changes or whatever mastectomies and
that's like
weirdly similar to what Iran does it's
very similar to what Iran does and it
was like what like four thousand four
hundred percent increase in young women
uh deciding to be trans so this was
interesting so you have all these young
women deciding to be trans seeing more
chocolate you have all these young women
deciding to be trans right around
puberty and they look at like the you
know they look at like Womanhood and
they're like I don't want any piece of
that that seems awful you've got like
the tampons you've got the whole thing
it's awful there's nothing it's hard to
see anything good about it right and so
they decide that they want to be boys
instead and they go through that whole
thing I was recently seeing I think it
was um a writer who does a lot of trans
writing and stuff is basically hitting
menopause like pre-menopause and being
like I am trans masculine now and it's
kind of this as it's the reverse of kind
of the same thing you're look she's
looking at Crone Hood she's looking at
being an old woman no one wants to be an
old woman even more than no one wants to
be a grown-up woman you could does
everything in your body just like sags
down it's terrible it's horrible nobody
wants any part of that and so now she's
going to be masculine she's getting a
breast binder and it's like yeah because
they're already like hanging down to
your navel probably you know it's not
like just
so no it's like the same kind of thing
like when a woman hits a change of life
whatever that change of life is she's
like I don't want any part of that
um and who can blame her it sucks well
also no I think that's a very good point
I mean girls are generally uncomfortable
during puberty there are a lot of
changes there and especially when you
look at the current cultural Paradigm
women are told not to want to do things
that are natural to women and also one
aspect of this people don't talk about
is that the average age of first
exposure to pornography is 13 years old
and there is really gross horrible
hardcore stuff out there and you can
absolutely imagine a girl encountering
that going oh my gosh that's what sex is
that's what happens to women no I don't
want to be a woman someone someone super
chatted that we should look at Noodles
the guitar player from the offspring's
reaction to uh kiss and I just want to
say this I know this is a bit personal
for me to say but this may be one of the
greatest days of my life
the guitar the guitarist from The
Offspring has me blocked the very first
song I ever learned how to play in the
guitar was the kids aren't all right
written by this man and he has blocked
me on Twitter truly a day for me to
behold is your cover that bad uh he's uh
he probably blocked me because you know
I'm friends and playing music with their
old drummer who they crapped all over
because they're nasty evil people mm-hmm
and uh man you know what I will say one
thing that frustrates me
is that there's a lot of secrets about
celebrities that if people only knew but
this guy from my understanding is lying
about everything really
I can't say much more it's not my place
to say and that bothers me but until
someone comes out and comes on the
record about the band and about their
actual uh um let's just say about the
truth there's not much more I can say
but what I will say is this many of
these people in Hollywood who post these
tweets do so just because they want to
get the pr brownie points and they voted
for Trump
oh and they voted for Trump for one
reason taxes taxes that's it they don't
care about anything yeah these people
that's why a lot of rappers will vote
for Trump because they're like into the
not having to pay us here's what any
rappers voted I don't believe any
rappers voted for Joe Biden I don't care
what they say publicly none of them
voted they're all like I'm voting for
Trump let me let me let me show you an
old creepy man let me let me show you
what noodles actually said I clicked his
Twitter account to see his response to
Paul Stanley and saw that I was blocked
he said this very disappointing take
especially from someone who wore high
heels makeup and teased up hair his
whole career as a young kid your band
helped teach me that I could be whatever
I wanted to be I guess it was just
gimmickery after all Ben Collins of NBC
says the idea of Kiss of all bands
complaining about gender non-conforming
people is just chef's kiss the funny
thing is he is of all the people to come
out and say kids should not be doing
this he is the perfect person in that he
wore high heels and makeup and he never
cut off his genitals he never did one
time
[Laughter]
[Applause]
children may dress and their brothers
and sisters clothes and that's just
something they want to do don't tell
them to to get surgeries and drugs and
they're coming on being like yeah but
you wore those clothes he said it's okay
that kids do you can't wear the clothes
it's so like that's the thing about drag
that drives me crazy too is you have all
this like drag for kids and it's like
guys drag is an adult thing we all had a
great time at the drag show why why are
we suddenly imagining that a bunch of
guys who dress up like campy women like
like fake beauty pageant women and have
uh taken on entertainment stage names
that are like sexual names for the most
part why are we imagining that these are
the people who should be entertaining
and educating our kids it doesn't make
any sense it's a horrible moment
like go to the drag show have a great
time get trashed enjoy yourself listen
I'm a little bit of a liberty in here
and there so but like I never had an
issue with that I've been to plenty of
drag shows you know I've had friends who
do drag but uh don't go hang out at my
kids Library doing Dragons It's not
surgery yeah and don't go reading them
books about how they should cut their
dicks off yeah well I think Matt Walsh
said it very well when he described drag
as burlesque for gay men sure it's
basically what it is rolling a bunch of
hacks too yeah
I think it's probably not politically
correct anymore to say that nothing's
politically correct anything as soon as
you open your mouth you're gonna get
okay I mean you showed up here at the
castle you were you're over it's done
um I I think that I think that the it's
obvious it should be obvious and I
really think that the average person
when they hear what goes on when it
comes to like surgeries and stuff
they're like that's not right that's not
that is so far outside of how we treat
any other issue that anyone has ever
like you don't cut up healthy bodies
because of psychological issues whether
it be AGP or whether it be
um dysmorphia or whatever you want to
call it right like I don't believe the
wrong body thing because I'm not a guy
that believes in a soul I think your
brain is your brain you're not born with
a man's brain woman's body you're born
with a woman's brain in a woman's body
or a man's brain in a man's body because
your brain is part of your body that's
it
um that's the physicalist approach yeah
I mean that's and that's how I I mean
I'm not a spiritual guy I'm you know
that's that's just my thing but also
gender isn't the soul like even if you
are a spiritual gender is not the same
well yeah yeah and it turned but that's
weird it's it becomes that whole creepy
weird religion thing that the life has
got going on yes well it's a cult
because there's no forgiveness I would
say just have forgiveness and I I would
add this in there as well I I do believe
in a soul but also I believe human
beings are a body Soul composite and you
are both it's not like you're a body and
you have a solar you're a soul and you
have a body you are your body and your
soul the idea that you are something
different from your body is a
contradiction it doesn't make sense
right
yeah
don't cut your wiener off yeah please
please yeah that was an excellent
response to the spiritual uh yeah I mean
no he's summer he summarized it let's
put it in layman's terms and I think
there is something you know I think
there is a spiritualness to having a
sexual life you know so I think it's
just really a crime too to destroy these
children's bodies before they have a
chance to be involved in loving
relationships 100 the the fact that that
there are so many people that Advocate
to do things
pre-puberty so because allegedly it
makes it it makes it easier to
transition which I don't believe because
there's the stories of jazz Jennings
like how her body
yeah yeah it's a train wreck because you
could not a good situation so anyways my
point being like I I can't see how and I
keep coming back to the same same point
I can't see how endorsing a surgery on
children people you know people that
haven't their brains haven't even fully
developed go by what the insurance
companies say the insurance companies
know you can't you know you know what
when I was 25 to rent a car like that's
it when I was 12 years old I knew that I
really wanted to do drugs like I was
very clear on that I was like oh that's
interesting I definitely want to do
drugs and I thought okay you're 12. so
maybe just like hold off
and I made a deal with myself I was like
okay you gotta hold off until you're 18.
and then you can try that's the most
mature thing I've ever heard a 12 year
old do I didn't think about drugs until
I was 15 and someone said you want to
smoke a joint I said yep well that way
well that way when somebody was 50 when
I was 15 and someone was like do you
want to smoke a joint I was like no I
gotta wait I actually had someone offer
me cocaine when I was 16 and I had
really wanted to do cocaine when I was
12. this was like one of the drugs
now I'll tell you the story another time
it's for the the after show definitely
an after show story all right anyways
um but yeah so someone offered me
cocaine when I was 16 and I was like you
know what I I have to wait until I'm 18.
all the drugs like LSD all the stuff I
was like I gotta I'm waiting on that
so I think when you're 12 you you have a
way to know like hey maybe I shouldn't
cut my boobs off
spaz shocking I was a alienated bullied
weirdo but I I knew some stuff yeah I
mean shockingly people don't know what's
best for them when they're younger I
remember a few years ago I was at a bar
with one of my cousins and we must have
been in our early 20s and the bartender
there was a bit older she was I believe
in her 50s and my cousin said something
like I'm never gonna have kids the
bartender goes how old are you and she
says I'm 22. Roger's like shut up
you you're 22 years old okay you're not
gonna sit here and tell me that you're
never gonna have kids because you don't
want to have them right now you're going
to get older and you're probably gonna
want them thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
show shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time